.
E CHAOTIC SCENES ARE NOT
BEING RE HERE.
WE WENT OUONHE STREETS FOR A
LIKE IIS NEW EMIRATEFE FELT
OF AFGHANISTAN.
AND WE FOUND A MOT F ALSO SOME
JUBILATION.
TAKE A WE OUR COMPOUND, IT'S C
THCATA
VICTORIOUS, THEY TOOK THE CITY
ON MATTE
OFOU.BARELY FIRINA SHOT.
THIS ISIGHT I HONESTLY
THOUGHT I WOULNER TAN
COMPOUND.ND US ESY
THEY'RE HER AW AND ORDER.
EVERYTHI IS UNDER CONTROL,
WILL
COMMANDER SAYS.
NOBODY SHOULD WORRY.R MESSE TO
READY SPENT ENOUGH
TIME IN GHN.
THEY NEED TOEA TELLS US.
AND LOTS OF MONEY.
PEOPLE COME UP TO THEM TO POSE .
CHANTINDEH TO
AMERIC BUT THEY SEEM FRIENDLY TE
BIZARRE.
A LOE ARE VERYFRIGHTENED THAT Y.
SINCE YESTERDAY, WE HAVED
THAT NOTHING WILL HAPPEN, AND WE
GIVE ASSURANCEO YOT
THEYL E, HE TELLS US,
AND  F
ONCE WE MAKE A PROMISE, WETI
MAINTAING AN
T LIST OPROMISES.NTL E GUARDING
TH LEFT WH
GOVERNMENTD.
E LCG SPIRIT
EXTENDS SOD MY PRESENCE ES
TENSION.
EY TO STAND
TO THEIDE BECAUSE I'M WOMAN.E T
IMPLEMENT THEIR DRIA ISLAMICT MY
READY PRG FOR ITYOTHIS BEAUTY S
RULE WILL BENTEDORE FRONTS OF V
GRADUALLY.
HOW WILL YOU?
BECAUSE MAOM
THEY WILBE ALLOWED TO GO
TO SCHOOWE W>> THE FEMALE, THE
NOT SAY ANYTHING.
THEY CAN GO TO THE SCHOOL, THEY
CAN CONTINUE THEIRONN ISLAMIC H.
>> LIKE I'M ARG
THEIR FACES.
>> COVER THE FACE.
>> YEAH.
>> WHY DO THEY HAVE COVER
TO WEAR ?E THIS  IM.S N ISLAM TH
>> OF COURSE.
IT IS IN I.ORDINARY AFGHANSSHOC.
STRULIO PROCESE LA24 HOUIS MAN
THE AFGHAN ARMY AND WAS KILLED
THIS SUMMER.W WHAT TDO.
>> IE LOSTTHING.'RE RA
I'M AFRAID.
I LOSTY DAD. MY MOM.
WO MONTHS
SORRY TO HEAR THAT.
SISTER.VING AAFRAID EVERYFOR US
MANY.
WALKINALNE HAS
THAT THE REAL Y BE THE
PEOPLE WHORE NOT ON TH
STS.
THOSE TOO AF TE THEIR
HOMES, TO SE  WILL BRING.
MAKE A PROMISE, WETICK.NG TOHEA
OBVIOUSLY, THINGS WERE SAI AND
W BETTER THAN ANYBODY,
IT'S PRETTY HORRIFIC IN
AFGHANISTAN WHENHEN RE.
YOU KNOW, THN MAKING
EDUCATION, IS
THERE REALLY ANYSON TO
BELIEVE THEMIT'S ONE THING TO,G
RTANT DISTINCTION
BETWEEWH THE
N OFEDUCATION, FOR EXAMPLEY
COUPLEEETHE CO OF TH
LOT OF THE HASD THE SAMELY, THE.
ROM OUR MISTAKESMEN WILL BE EDU
SL,GHNI
BHEY WANT
.
SUDDENLY THEY SAY, ONCE WOMEN EN
HIT PUBERTY, THEY CAN'T TUALLY
TE THEE BUILDING BOYS, BECSEY B
BEEN BUILT, THESE WOMEDOEND UP
GETTIN.HER THYOA LOT,
ANICULAR
PLACKE KABULBU
THERE'ST A FFERENT MENTALITSO'U
SUPPOSED TO SEND THEIRIR LITTLE
YEARS, MAYBEL A FE
SO EVEN IF T T SAY PERMISS, WIY
THE U.S. HERE TOT OF E
ITN ACTIVELY
DE
OR WILL WEASHEIS, THE
VERY RFED OBMORE LIKELY SCENARI
ONCE
R IN THAT YOLK YNG AT
CLARISSA WARD, THANK YOU FOR
G
T PERSPECTIVE FR .
THOMAS FRIEDMAN, "NEW YOOREIGN
BOOKS.
SO TOM, I METING, YOU SEAGPREST.
WHAT OF HOARE UNFOLDING?
>>AN.EAMBLE
ABOUT MAKING AIONS.
THE THING THAT RLLY STRIKES ME
T CARLYAREFULY, WHAT THEY TRY O
LEAVGETH PROCESS OVE
BU, IN D
KNOW.
THEY'RE TAKING OR A COUNTRY
THVERY DIFFEREM TH A
P F SHOULD LLIONS OF WOMEN HAV
PEOPLE HE ORKING WITH E WEST
UNIVOPENED. HAVE GOT TO
IGE UT
THEY NOW OWN IT.HINE, IFINS DON
SEWERSK ING TO
BE RESPONSIBLE NOW.D  FOREIGN A
O PL
THER.
I THINEY'RE JUST FEELING
THEIR WAY,TO LD.>> IN TERMS OF
IDEOLOGYTHI EY
HAVEN'T CHANGED THEIIEY T
OF I WOULDN'T EXPECT.RTAINLY NON
LATED
REKNOWRELYCK TIMES I HAVE BEEN
ITAT'S KABUL. REALLY  THE BIG ,D
COURSE. EVAL'S GOING
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IN HEES."
T ITRANSITION IN ULD BE ASSURED
OF SAFELY REMOVA, T TO MENTIOND
LLD INEXPLICABLE. AI
DO YOU T
D THAT TAY YOUNO TY' THAT THEY'
BE TENS OF
THS OF AFGHANS AND THEIRFAMILIER
PETHAN
THEY WEREN'T PREPARED.AINLY MADA
IT'S INTERESTING TE OFAT THE TA.
THEY CLEARLY WERE  DADUNGICIALS
THE PROVINCIAL GOVERNMT TO TAKEO
REALIZED.
N AIWHY AND HOW ITW.BUT I  THE O
THE PRESIDENT SAIDAY
PUT WHEVEY NEETHERE.E IS ARS
AT E EVERAIRPORAN
HE
E  OPE ATHAVE STHT OF IT.
THE WORST WAS NOT